welcome back from the break everyone
appreciate it uh sticking with us we
have a special guest today bad brad
berkwit from the bad brad berkwitch show
brad thank you for joining us how are
you today i'm doing well thanks tony hey
gabe what's up buddy hey i'm doing good
you i'm doing well
oh we're we're doing fantastic i watched
the uh interview that uh you did with
gabe um
gabe sanchez
is that your last name gabe who
i should rebrand it to gabe
yeah yeah just change it i am gabe who
exactly
no no i i enjoyed i enjoyed the
interview there was a lot of things that
uh i learned about gabe that i did not
actually know um from the interview
which is good um you know a lot of
things that i'll probably hold against
him
so you know absolutely why not i i kind
of you know i kind of give him um wow i
spoke so highly of you i don't know i
know i didn't see that part i didn't i
actually knife right in my back i
actually cut that part and i i've been
replaying that part over and over and
over you've been playing you've been
playing if you're a kid so you're like
listen to this guy he's got respect
exactly when he goes on his walks right
before he says [ __ ] him he listens to
you saying oh he's a beautiful human
being and he says yeah very empathetic
[ __ ] yes right so
so brad you do you do these 360
interviews and you've had you've had a
lot you had mary trump on your show of
course you've been anthony scaramucci
that's kind of how we got connected with
anthony is through you and i really
appreciate that
but you've done you've done a lot of
other big interviews but not just in
politics in the world of boxing because
you have this website called ringside
report i believe it is yes and you came
from the boxing world but tell us i i
enjoy your 360 interviews
we're more of the shoot to [ __ ] here
you're much more structured so tell us
about those interviews tell us about
yourself now introduce you introduce
yourself to our audience
okay
i was actually born a poor
non-loving trump child no
you know a movie that's from you know
what gabe you know a movie that's right
the jerk remember the jerk oh yeah we're
in the media yeah yeah
so
you you hit on it with the boxing stuff
uh
first and foremost
i'm a new yorker if you can't pick that
up in the in the forget about it right
and the pinky ring and i do that shtick
because i don't want people to ever
think that i'm from northwest indiana
because my better half debbie got a job
working at british petroleum in white
indiana but the minute
she retires i'm pulling up with the dogs
in the u-haul truck and we're getting a
f out of here i'm trying to recurse too
early into the thing no no you can curse
all you want
i know i know are you are you going back
to florida then is that the is that i
don't know i i would love to go back to
new york but i'm trying to stay away
from cold weather so actually it's funny
i said it because on the way back from i
took debbie to pt today on the way back
she was like you know we need to figure
out where we're going to retire to after
this and we're like texas is out because
abbott and all them are such [ __ ]
even though it's about 10 15 years down
the road but we have to see where these
states are at at that point so i'm not
sure where we're going
baby
and we talked about california only
thing is with california so ridiculously
as you know well it's so expensive i
mean i don't even understand why it's so
damn expensive out there i visited there
in 2011 and it's just insane but i'm not
ruling it out because i do love
california and it's good for the
entertainment industry but
you hit on it you talked about boxing
um
born in new york
moved to florida with my parents divorce
when i was seven years old in 1975.
lived in florida lived in new york
that's the two biggest places before i
joined the military uh in 86
and you always said we say 20 years in
28 days and for your viewers that say
how the [ __ ] is it 28 days brad you're
exaggerating no let me explain it
because i've had explained it before
i came in september 2nd
1986
and i retired september 30th 2006 so on
my dd214 that all of these patriots that
aren't that don't know
and attack the [ __ ] capital on
january 6th
which you get when you retire or you get
out the military 20 years and 28 days
during the gulf war with papa bush i was
in country i was flying missions i
wasn't a pilot i was flying classified
missions and then uh the iraq war i was
in the pentagon under papa
are under bush junior so that's when you
see me say war and peace it was war and
peace because you you guys know my line
if you don't i'll say it for your
viewers for all those [ __ ] that
attack the capital and that are not
patriots who always want to talk about
colin
kaepernick
offended us which he did not offend me
one bit as being a retired military
most of those people
tony never even served in the [ __ ]
salvation army right let alone the
united states army but they have an
opinion
on my service and i don't speak for all
veterans i only speak for me i know how
this veteran feels and the shadow box
behind me is my life in the military so
i i come from a um a place that i can
talk on these type of things where these
people on twitter
or marjory taylor no bobard had
lieutenant corporal there's a [ __ ]
such thing she took an officer rank in
enlisted rank and put it together so i
if so i was a petty officer first class
so i think i'm going to be a rear
admiral petty officer
there may have been there may have been
someone who did a video about that i
don't know it's possible
yeah of course gabe did a video about it
yeah it was a facetime call with uh bobo
okay okay yeah we'll we'll send that
over what's in that absolutely i gotta
say and then the boxing side was
uh my father got arrested so turned me
onto boxing 1975 again when i was seven
and from 80 to 83
i was an amateur boxer uh down in north
miami beach florida and i fought all
over florida and so on we'll probably
talk about that later on i want to get
ahead of you but um so that's where the
boxing stuff comes in and you're right
tony like i said the shirt i wore for
you guys today here the heart of boxing
uh
ringsidereport.com but
it's not just boxing anymore like gabe
talked about yesterday and i concurred i
never expected to be in the position
that i am now but when trump got elected
i changed my show i made a comeback um
in the height of covid and i went from
strictly boxers
to
political people
entertainers but more moving humanity
forward which is my tagline
and talking about trump and what's going
on in the country so my my show has done
a a complete 180 from all boxers and
i've you know been in this game for 25
years so
i'm more set now going in the direction
i am still another sport of boxing i
don't like where it's went with all
these [ __ ] pay-per-views or the paul
brothers fighting floyd mayweather one
of them that's all that's as we say it's
a fugazi it's all [ __ ] that's not
conor mcgregor when floyd fought conor
mcgregor went to 50 you know he carried
him the fight was fixed it was a joke so
that's the boxing side you got a
ringstar report
but ringside report as well is um
politics world news entertainment social
issues and our hashtag i got a very
diverse writing team is hashtag
moving humanity forward like you guys
are doing on your platform that's what
it's all about well we appreciate them
we appreciate you being in the fight for
your service in the military and your
service to your country after i i think
i think um some of the interviews you do
are are absolutely fantastic you take
deep dives um into those interviews i
i've watched
i went back and watched several i
actually that's how i did a little bit
of research on um anthony scaramucci is
is went and watched is went and wants
your your interviews that you had
now
um i want to get to a clip of your
father because you brought up your
father here a minute ago
um and i think that might have a lot to
do with
um why you entered politics but before
we get to tell me tell me
what made you go from
hey it's just strictly boxing because
you were originally like a writer right
not necessarily i tell them i was a yeah
i was a journalist i started in the game
in 1997 so 25 of course that's right now
um and i was writing about boxing i made
my bones doing boxing interviews george
foreman kenny norton chuck whitney you
name angelo dundee who trained ali who's
behind you knocking out sunday yeah yeah
i want to i want to ask about that story
too yeah yeah so yeah i started there i
was always i always fought for social
issues
but i did it in my circles i never
tolerated racism i never tolerated
discrimination against women and stuff
like that but i didn't get into the
political side
until
donald [ __ ] trump and i was like
that's it i can't do this no more
like i said covet hit
and
uh my dear friend marielle trump said
hey you got to do interviews on zoom
because i was doing them i used to do
them on the phone dude i used to do them
where i'd record them from cassette and
type them back and take hours and if you
had a long interview it's three hours of
transcribing so
then we went to debbie and i created the
bad brad birkwood show when we were in
oklahoma
and i was interviewing local mma guys
because it kind of branched out in mma
too
boxing
but when covet hit and i couldn't
interview anybody anymore in the house
because i had a office slash studio my
earlier shows was all fighters
i made the comeback with mary mary was
one said hey brad you got to do them on
zoom and once you do zoom or like this
platforming trip it opens up the world
which it did because as you guys have
done i've interviewed people in scotland
and england and canada and all over the
united states so this is the format
that i'm going gonna stain unless i ever
get picked up and they put me in the
studio somewhere and you know i don't
edit i don't do anything anymore and i'm
just in front of the camera but that
that's how it that's how it started for
me to get into the political side i
couldn't recover i saw trump on the tv
every single [ __ ] day put a light up
your ass and drink bleach and all the
stupid [ __ ]
dr foucher who i have much respect for
get attacked because of trump
that is what got me into the political
part the activism side was there
because my father would just show the
clip yeah that side was there fighting
for uh native americans uh speaking out
on behalf of the african-american
community i'm in an interracial
relationship my son is is biracial so
that's always been there that part
because that's my dad that's my father
and me but the political side came with
trump
right well and i i want to play this
clip um that shows you're dead now this
is this is kind of a a famous clip in
that it was in the movie milk correct is
that our part of it was yes yes and i'll
tell you i'll tell you the story however
you want me to yeah well yeah
tell us tell us a little bit about your
dad before i play the clip and then
we'll play the clip and then maybe you
can tell the story about how it came to
be that you even knew that this was in
the movie milk yeah tell us a little bit
about your dad yeah so my father god
rest his soul stood five too he was joe
pesci before joe
and that's
everyone's going to see that in the clip
you're dead you're dead now his name is
alvin correct
yeah he he definitely is uh pre-dates
joe pesci like like i think they
actually model a lot of joe pesci
characters after you're dead maybe well
my dad everyone sees the clip to
understand yeah well my dad actually
acted he didn't make it big big i got
all those acting pictures in my house
framed on the wall but he didn't have
the patience to deal with and gave you
notice to get in the sag and all the ass
kissing and he went to jerry lewis all
kinds of stories during the show but he
tried to talk to jerry lewis who was in
charge one time i think he might have
been president couldn't get in so he
left hollywood
but he still had that little you know
that joe pesci you know you got
something to say to me you know that
type of stuff so
that clip
he took on anita bryant who was very
famous in the 1970s
speaking she was she was against the gay
community my dad took on any cause
whether it was for back then and he says
in a clip where do you see a negro on
this beach tell me and in context that
was 1977. so that's what you know back
in 77 they would say the word negro now
we say african americans but he fought
for african american rights he fought
for gay rights and that clip is anita
bryant
took her on
they kicked their ass
on miami beach they had a thing that
they were trying to say if a teacher is
gay and teaches your student
your kid is going to turn gay which is
absolutely unsteady that sounds pretty
similar to what's going on right now
like right
in florida believe it or not yeah that's
the craziest one
here and yeah and if right full circle
and one thing i do want to tell your
viewers that is a smack in the face of
anita brian if you don't know her story
her granddaughter just married a woman
so that's like a kick in her ass for
hating the game
and she's still talking [ __ ] so that
that's the clip of my dad now yes they
took a piece of it and put in the movie
milk so what happens in 2009 my dad had
been uh have been dead then 11 years
because he died in 98. so i get a call
from west coast i'm saying hey
i'm pretty sure your father's in milk
i'm like how could he be in milk because
he's passed away
i never thought public footage because
guys i didn't know about this clip
i had to see you didn't know this
existed before
before it was in the movie no i i i was
there when he fought against anita
bryant right and i knew about that i
knew when he would protest he had the
signs and all that
excuse me but i didn't know about the
clip
so somebody else hits me up and says hey
i'm telling you your dad is in this
movie here's about the time whatever it
was okay kid you're not you can't make
this up i'm living in virginia
and i come downstairs to get something
out of the refrigerator it's about 1 30
1 40 in the morning and i turn on the tv
and you cannot make this [ __ ] up hbo and
boom
the clip starts because he wasn't the
only one in the in the public domain
that the footage they use it was ray it
was jerry brown
ronald reagan when he was governor my
dad and then some other schmuck and
actually the guy that's talking at the
end my dad lit that guy up but you
that's the footage you know i got others
so
being in the media
i reached out to somebody and they gave
me a name of the guy that his name was k
is still is he still alive ken rabin
and he actually took that public footage
because the first day i said you get
paid for it i'm like it's public footage
you can't get paid right right now
because it's a it's an mb it's it's an
nbc archive right it's nbc archive right
now but if my father were alive he might
not be able to get some money for it but
i'm telling you guys my father was a
character he would have had me get eight
by tens he would have been trying
and all of that and and everything else
i get in touch with him he says yes your
father is the one with the hat on and it
was the most dynamic i i cut and pasted
i think i sent your article where he
said it was the most dynamic footage in
the that we used
so
he says look contact nbc at rockefeller
center and this is the guy tell them i
sent you
they'll they can get you probably that
on dvd well not only did he get me that
he got me the footage that didn't quite
make the tv when the guy when my dad
thought i got to kiss his ass
the guy at the end of that clip in milk
you don't see that in nbc so they used a
little piece of that and the clip that
you have is the whole
piece and that's how i became aware now
now this is this is this a reporter like
from nbc that was filming this do you
know no they did a whole piece no it was
a whole it was not just my dad it was a
whole piece on anita bryant and the bill
that they were trying to get past at the
time i see and it was a whole story that
started out in san francisco because
they had a gay parade and the guys were
in a car in drag and this is like in 77.
well right but but but
how did the how did that how did the
camera get right there in that moment
with your dad because oh because
there was there was nbc somehow i don't
know how honestly i can't answer how
they got there but the movement was so
strong against anita bryant that they
they must have been following them and
they they got my dad and i'm running the
right thing i mean i mean that the rant
that you're gonna see is is phenomenal
um and i don't blame any movie maker
anywhere putting this this footage
inside of a movie especially about this
topic um and how they found this i have
no idea but it's it's a beautiful piece
that now it's not the only activism that
your dad did we're going to show this
piece but there's there's a couple other
videos that you have in your youtube
channel of your dad even like going to
like school board meetings and stuff
like that
he he did not [ __ ] around like like if
he believed in something he didn't care
he would stand there and he would tell
you exactly what he believed whether you
gave rather you gave two shits or not he
would stand there and tell you exactly
what he believed because he believed it
he had conviction yeah
is that is that where you kind of draw
your because i know you do that on your
show a lot yeah um is that kind of what
you think where you draw from is 100 i
grew up like this my father taught me
that you don't judge i know martin
luther king said it too but he said you
don't judge a person by the color of
their skin but the content their soul
the janitor is no no better or worse
than the fortune 500 ceo and the guy on
the street that may be down now might
have been the fortune 500 ceo so you
talk to people like he always is saying
was you know i always end my shows with
what's the same my father's
old
it's cliche but it's all one you want
others as they as you want done unto you
that was the way i was raised in in the
third grade i wrote a book report
on native americans
and and we said indians say native
americans then but indians the way they
were treated by this country and
black people
and i had a third grade teacher named mr
stratton that cut me off in the middle
of my book report and said you can't say
that well when my dad found out he went
to the school
and he got the principal in there and
the teacher and he said you will never
this is true you will never
cut my son off again because first of
all it's his book report second of all
what he's talking about you may not like
it as a third as him being a third
grader in 1977
but it's the truth right again again
full circle happening right now right
full circle right
so yes tony and answer your question it
all comes from my dad it's it's
ingrained in me
to to take up for the underdog and
whoever it was
my father
um would take her for the underdog and
at a per you always heard me say to you
guys i said to you yesterday at a
personal cost there was no social media
then they would go to his car because my
dad's side of family is jewish
my mother's side is italian and my
running joke is
it
when my book came out i always tell
people i said well tell us about stuff i
said well the jewish side likes things
at a discount and in the italian side
they're expensive so the jewish side
wants them at a discount
my dad it might not be politically
correct but i'm still well you know yeah
say it you can say that
but
my dad would walk back to his car
and they put swat stickers on his
volkswagen and where he had to take it
to the paint place to get it taken off
so they or they would attack him and now
my dad would fight back he used to carry
a 38 i could steal a weapons permit so
he would fight back but when i say at a
personal cost
and it wasn't just him was people in
that group that wasn't popular you know
a lot of a lot of activism now for the
people that aren't really serious about
it but they're trying to do it just to
make a name but they're not they're
their hearts not in or doing it for bad
or for [ __ ] reasons yeah
that's on social media where it's easy
he did it in person where you get the
[ __ ] kicked out of you or whatever would
happen so yes everything is from my dad
yeah there was no blue check mark back
then that you could cloud chase
you know social justice this is legit
[ __ ] right roll it out what what year
is this clip from that we're gonna show
june 2nd
1977 the nbc nightly news it was a it
was a clip it was a whole piece on anita
bryant and it had showed her too because
she said i love the gays or something
like that you know i'm christian and but
you know
that she sounded like mike pence with
boobs or
or well
i was thinking of donald trump when he
would say there's my black person over
there right there's my african-american
that's actually that's what he would say
that's what he would say
yeah well you know and um i think it's
um
appropriate that you have the attitude
that you have with trump because he is
the epitome of hating the underdog right
everyone everyone acts like he's some
kind of blue collar billionaire whatever
the [ __ ] that's supposed to mean but
this guy this guy absolutely looks down
upon every anyone who is not him or
maybe ivanka but absolutely everyone he
looks down upon so let's play the clip
of your dad here real quick
okay
this country was all negroes and you
were what and they took your rights away
from you because you were white and they
killed you three four and five-year-old
children in churches now now what would
you say white man tell me
that's not what are you gonna sound the
hell it is you think the negro's equal
where do you see one in this speech show
me
they had signs no dogs in jerusalem are
you jewish
yeah no dogs and jews are like i lived
here when i saw the sign okay it's not
that close where anita bryant belongs to
where they don't allow negroes and jews
i like to see you and rabbi redding for
the rest of those jews walk in the front
the day you can walk in that front door
bath club that's the day i'll join you
guys i am voting for negro jews gays i
belong to human beings if you allow one
just one human being to be allowed to
have his rights taken away from him as a
human being that pal you don't have any
right when they have to take away your
rights because if you say screw you to
them they say screw you to you and six
million more jews line up in the toilet
and i'm not gonna wind up with him
and i'm a jew and i've got that part of
my job and i'll say it's not a joke
a human being
okay
the passion like the
you could just in his eyes you could see
just how much he [ __ ] just like he
cared about it he was serious meanwhile
you know the other schmuck over there
was like okay yeah sure let's just shake
it away you know and they're like i'll
just walk away from it he's like no [ __ ]
this like i i am i believe this is where
i stand [ __ ] you like it was very yeah
very passionate well uh you got one hell
of a pops there that's that's for damn
sure and and i'll tell you that uh that
for 1977
for a guy his size and for him to be a
jew as he said standing on the street
um to defend
uh people's right to be gay at that time
because i think that's what you're
saying he was he was defending it at
that time oh yeah
um in 1977 as a jew to stand on the
street not just not just to say
something but to be holding stuff in
your hand and to be talking to people
and to be out outright uh vocal about
that opinion at that time yeah that was
that was a tough thing to do that was
probably not easy like you said he would
get a lot of pushback um even in that
public space
i don't i don't think a lot of folks
understand
um just how far things have come now
we're not perfect um you know obviously
obviously we're not perfect we have we
we have in the same state that your
father was standing on the sidewalk
there in 1977 we have them now uh
passing a don't say gay bill um in that
same state which seems to be the the
opposite of what your dad was fighting
for so
um if we get a little more your alvin
berkwit energy in florida that would be
fantastic um actually in a lot of states
texas and the like where they're trying
to pass a lot of uh
anti-lgbtq
community uh bills um where they're
trying to ostracize these people from
society
but um in 1977
that is that is almost i believe almost
as
almost as brave as them being against
these people today because i think don't
don't you think don't you think this is
not a very uh uh popular road for these
fascists to go down like i believe most
americans are like you know i think you
should just love whoever the [ __ ] you
want to love and leave people to [ __ ]
alone i mean rather rather you believe
in gay marriage or not or whatever your
stance is most people just want other
people to be left the [ __ ] alone because
they don't want people to [ __ ] with them
tony this is what i say and and i always
try to call it right down the middle
i don't have a problem honestly if you
if if you're if you really are religious
and you go by the bible whatever that's
that's your thing if you have a problem
with uh gay marriage or gay couples i'm
not gonna tell you what your opinion
should be what it shouldn't be but what
i will tell you is if you claim you're a
christian you don't treat somebody
because they're a man loving a man a
woman love it a woman or they're
transgender whatever it is whatever it
is you have no right to treat a human
being less than because you don't you
don't have to like the lifestyle but you
don't have the right to treat a human
being
less than because they're gay it's the
same thing when i say with colin
kaepernick you have a right in america
not the like that he took a knee
i'm the opposite i'm for it i take a
knee with her if you call me right now
and said hey brad i'm taking a knee at
seventh and grand i'm gonna go there
with him come with me i'll take a knee
and i'll let the world know i was in the
military and take a knee with them but i
don't say that people don't have the
right
to not like that he took a knee what i
won't allow on my platform or anybody
that comes around me is to change the
[ __ ] narrative of why colin took the
knee right because it's huge and trump
with his [ __ ] about son of a [ __ ]
players and all that is [ __ ] trump
first of all couldn't take a knee
because a fat bastard couldn't get back
up from taking a knee
he makes the narrative up and they make
the narrative up with them and i know
though you guys know the story what kind
of want to get off too much of it you
know the story about it was a military
guy nate boyer said that
but but it's not even that again this is
america i tell people they say well what
do you mean
i don't want you to stop the kkk from
marching down the street i'll tell you
why because if you stop the kkk from
marching down the street then the three
of us don't get to march down the street
anymore either what you do is you fight
back against that [ __ ] you speak out and
you use your platform i'm not condoning
to go over there and bash your head in
with a cinder block i know a lot of
people say well that's what we should do
i'm not condoning that okay but what i
am saying is
they have the right to do it because
this is america i don't want anybody to
lose the right but we got to push back
on this [ __ ] right and
this whole freedom of speech thing
it goes too far because what these
politicians are doing
with power to me is more than freedom of
speech what fox news is doing is more
than freedom of speech
going back and tying that into my father
my father would be speaking out against
uh tokyo rose and all of these clowns
beau barton he would be at them
every single [ __ ] day i would love to
i would pay to see him oh yeah go
toe-to-toe with these
you know the thing is and i want to
remind your viewers that wasn't
rehearsed i mean i know it all in my
head i could do the thing verbatim
because i've watched it so many times
that was off the top of his head because
as gabe said he felt that right you know
when he said if you allow one just one
human being to have his rights taken
away from them as a human being then and
he said pal because he was a new yorker
that's a new york thing then powell you
don't have any rights when they come to
take away your rights
if you don't understand what he's saying
because he's yelling it then you you
absolutely are clueless because it's the
truth no matter what 77 or 2022 if we
allow one african-american one member of
the lgbtq community one member hispanic
community one caucasian person to to
lose
their rights even if we don't like what
they're doing then everybody's going to
wind up losing them that's right it's a
slippery slope you know it's one of
those things i saw i think uh it was
today i was going through instagram and
a clip came up of gabrielle union and
she was doing a promo for uh cheaper by
the dozen they did a remake of it yeah
yeah yeah it's a movie on netflix is
that right uh disney i think oh yeah
that's right yeah okay okay but in the
clip you know it she's
with variety she's talking about these
rights taken away from the lgbtqia
community and she's like listen if you
think that's just the them problem right
you are sorely mistaken babe like i'm
telling you right now if they can go
after them they will surely in some time
later in the future come after you so
you better defend these these people
this group right here because if you
don't then you're next yeah and that's
you know exactly what your dad was
saying i was saying i can't believe it's
from 1977 to 2022 uh your dad is down in
miami defending people's right to have
their the sexual identity that they want
and here we are with uh gabrielle union
in an interview having to say the same
[ __ ] in 2022 but here's here's here's
the the fact of the matter is is that
you're right with the freedom of speech
and the freedom of thought just as much
as uh you know
you know they'll call us liberals or
libtards or whatever socialist kind
whatever the hell they'll call us right
um
just as much as we're entitled to our
opinion they're entitled to theirs but
where it starts to cross the line is
when you legislate um me and me and gabe
played a video and i posted this video
on dick doc
um from denton texas uh it's at the
university of north texas where uh jeff
younger who's trying to run for congress
he has a transgender daughter he tried
to not have her be transgender um he's
he's a bigoted piece of [ __ ] this guy's
a full-on fascist uh he even tries to go
around different universities to give
presentations and this that the students
at this university protested him and in
the clip that i posted on tick tock
which it's got a lot of views uh it's
got like five and a half million views
uh just on my tic tac so i don't know
how many tens of millions of views that
it has but it's gotta have a lot because
these these these students are chanting
[ __ ] these fascists
and the one the one comment i get from
all these
they're white supremacists they may not
know it but they are um
i'm serious they they may not know they
are but that's what they are right right
they'll say they'll say oh why couldn't
this these students let him have his
opinion he can have his opinion you get
to hold your opinion no one is forcing
him to be in prison because jeff younger
thinks a certain way but what jeff
younger wants to do
jeff younger wants to put people in
prison because they think are a certain
way and that's what they don't really
understand about fascism about freedom
of speech and and
oppressing rights is
and i say it all the time it's in our
intro i i the quote is from me the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people
is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating morons
and and let me say again the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty because we don't really
everyone you know i get this from these
stupid freedom convoy and people convoy
morons they they talk about mandates
they [ __ ] that they can't go get
whoppers because they're not backs all
this nonsense look we strive for liberty
in this country that's what we strive
for the rights and the freedoms are
actually what delivers us that liberty
and i believe a lot of your content is
spot on because
your number one
uh your number one word that you use a
lot is humanity and like that's what i
try to tell people is like
you know you may think someone is out
there you may think someone is weird you
may think their lifestyle is not what
you want you may you may not agree with
everything they're saying
even fascists like i don't agree with
fascist but by god they get the right to
hold their fascist bigoted views they
get to be a racist if they want to be a
racist i mean lindsey graham i think's
the one that was there lindsey graham or
was it was it lindsey graham today
yeah well no he today he was talking in
in the kanji uh brown jackson hearing he
said we uh they're gonna say racist
stuff about us or say that we're racist
which is par for the course we're used
to that lindsey graham basically said
he's used to be calling a racist like
well i mean i guess if you have to say
i'm used to that that's par for the
course that's probably a bad sign like
you shouldn't just brush and be like
it's it is what it is it's like no if
people are calling you racist and you're
used to that and you're just like
whatever
we're in a conversation lgbtq right
i can't tell you 100 lindsay graham is
gay but i can tell you 100 that i
believe lindsay gamma is great okay and
this is what i don't understand about
lindsey
and i'm going to call him lady g because
i can't stand them
there's my problem
the republican party wants to get people
in why doesn't he come out the closet
and use his platform and help the lgbtq
community and say hey look we
republicans take a lot of [ __ ]
i'm gay you know lindsey graham's saying
i'm gay
want i'm going to fight for you no
desantis you're not going to do this in
florida this is wrong because you know
barney frank you know bonnie frank was
yeah
you know but no ah lindsey graham wants
to pretend he's not gay and whatever
whatever the case may be you don't want
to use this platform because he wants to
go with their evil with the evil
[ __ ] of that party
and you would have thought that
when he said in gabe talk and i talked
about this yesterday when he said trump
was he is a zen
and a homophobe and he's gonna get our
troops killed over there you do a pretty
good lindsey graham you know that you do
pretty good
[ __ ] scary but
you know he says that [ __ ]
and then he's down there washing his
balls you know it might be maybe his
golf balls but washing his bowl golfing
with him now he's wonderful i mean it's
it's it's it's
[ __ ] insanity yeah i i mean i mean go
ahead the game i was gonna say it is
unfortunate that you've got you know we
kind of talked with yesterday when you
asked me about like hispanic community
and why they might support trump you
know and kind of the mentality that's
there and i think that's also true with
the republican party is like
the group is known for a set of ideals
conservative values christian catholic
whatever and if you are you know being
gay and religious not okay yeah you know
and so
it is sad and unfortunate that if you
are
you know uh one way or the other that
you have to
um appear as if you are a straight you
know cis you know gendered man and you
you could not be gay you could not be
trans you cannot be this you cannot be
that like you have to
regardless of how you actually feel and
how you truly are you have to put this
image this facade up as i'm a straight
white man or whatever you know and it's
it's it's unfortunate and even if he
were to come out and say that you know i
am gay and i'm part of the republican
community and i will fight for your
rights like
i i could easily see them going okay
let's time to primary this [ __ ]
like that's what it would come down to
because they it's this group this this
peer pressure this group mentality where
they would take over and say you're not
like us
you're out yeah and that's soon it's
like us versus them kind of that's how
they're mentally
the most simple
talking point to that
i'm not a fan of this cheney i i think
they give her far too much credit yes
she's doing the right thing i'll give
her credit with the january commission
adam kinder both of them i'll give him
credit for that 93 of the time liz
cheney voted more with trump than
[ __ ] uh i don't take a bath [ __ ]
jim jordan so
i'm not i'm not with and and kenneth and
cheney voted for [ __ ] trump in 2020.
after all of that [ __ ] that he did okay
i wouldn't care if they wrote somebody
in i wouldn't care if they wrote their
own name in i know they weren't gonna
vote for president biden that's your
right that's fine but not this
[ __ ] trump
they if you tell the truth in the
republican party you're [ __ ] out
right yep the truth just the simple
truth that that was the insurrection
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] don't you go
ahead and ask me something about it i
feel about veterans because you know
what i'm gonna say
about january 6 was a [ __ ]
insurrection and they told the truth
about it and they're out cheney's out
you got that little [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] pedophile that i've challenged him
to three rounds to get a [ __ ] ring
with me don jr him and [ __ ] cruz all
three of them not threatening their
lives because i don't do that
cherry like i told gabe i'll put a
[ __ ] certain amount up these bastards
put a certain amount of the winner which
is going to be me goes to my charity of
choice it'll go to the lgbtq community
just to shove it up their ass even more
because
they talk all the [ __ ] but the truth
gets you out of the republican party the
[ __ ] truth
so elijah if like gabe said if you're
supporting lgbtq oh you're you're [ __ ]
get across and burn you
you know my mother mother p i call her
him penis people like to correct me it's
mike penis because he's a dick
mother penis
teaches
at a school that doesn't let gay kids go
there yeah but you're christian right
right you're christian but you know uh
george carlin speaking of new yorkers
and christians and the lgbt community
george carlin once famously said that
who who other than uh homosexuals have
less abortions these two people should
be natural allies christians and [ __ ]
he said that in one of his bits i
believe it was in
1994 if i am correct okay that's when
george crown george garland
but but you know
i don't understand why
that the republican party
couldn't um you know broaden their tent
to and welcome these other than their
bigotry but but they you know you and
you and gabe actually talked about this
on on your interview with gabe you
talked about how they kind of courted
the latino vote where they really have
tapped into the conservative ideas and
you know originally that was lindsey
graham's
idea back in 2008 when obama had won and
basically swept the latino vote um and
the republican party did this uh autopsy
and they found out that uh latinos don't
like the republicans that much and um
lindsey graham actually did an interview
and i forget with who but i'm sure it's
out there that could be pulled where he
basically said
you know he used to be for immigration
reform lindsey graham did like he was he
was one of the proponents he was quote
unquote with the maverick john mccain
um on some of the immigration reform he
was more progressive when it came to
immigration you know the republicans
kind of torched him for that a lot um
but he actually said there's
these these people
coming to this country they're more
conservative than some of the white
conservatives that are here there are
natural allies to the republican party
but you know i think that is the actual
rub that we have here is it's no longer
about ideas it's no longer about
ideology it's only about power it's only
about pure power to trump and the trump
allies and they'll do anything say
anything to hold power it has nothing to
do with legislation right there's
nothing to do with policy no and you
know you mentioned lindsey graham
all jokes aside i mean i could do a
[ __ ] 10 minute skit at him but all
jokes aside
this guy's not a good person for example
you you said the maverick john mccain
right he him
and and uh joe lieberman who was the
vice president nominee for uh for gore
were supposed to be the three of them
were the three amigos they were supposed
to be like this
so
trump lowers the [ __ ] flag when and
and i like john mccain i didn't like his
policies but i respected the man i knew
him not personally but i had some
dealings with him actually believe it or
not with the boxing side because he was
a big boxy fan and he got the muhammad
ali act passed under his watch so
lindsay was supposed to be great friends
with him when donald trump treated him
like [ __ ] lindsay didn't come to his
defense didn't come to his defense at
all he was also if you know that you
guys are probably not you remember when
i believe it was john mccain lindsey
graham i think hillary clinton went
overseas and did that tour i forget what
it was but they're pretty sure it's the
three of them
he was friends with hillary now you can
have a difference of policies we can
argue that night and day but if she's
your [ __ ] friend you piece of [ __ ]
she's your friend but you're letting
this guy say all this horrible [ __ ]
about her because whether you like john
mccain or not
the man had integrity i'm sure people
said no he didn't yes he did because
when he stood up that lady at that
debate or not the debate at that speech
and he said she said president obama uh
he wasn't president that he's a muslim
or he's an arab or whatever the hell she
said it was so [ __ ]
i think i think even she got to the
point to where she thought he was a
terrorist maybe right yeah he said he
grew the mic from her and he said no
ma'am he's not he's a good man he's a
family man if i didn't he said if i
didn't think i'd be a better president
then i wouldn't be running or something
paraphrasing what he said he stood up
for him because that was the right thing
to do
lindsey graham and all of them they let
donald trump say the most vile
narcissistic misogynistic
racist [ __ ] and like i told i think i
told davis whoever it was i was talking
to recently
you don't get if they like you tony and
you're a racist but you you say funny
things say well i like the funny stuff
he says but the racist stuff i don't
like that right they own all of me
all of you and i don't mean owen as in
we're we're a slave or or property i
mean
the person you don't get to pick and
choose what traits of donald trump you
like or you don't like you own it all
right and with him everything's [ __ ]
up so you're even worse to me yeah you
can't yeah that we were talking about
yesterday when we did the interview and
it's yeah you can't pick and choose you
can't nitpick and be like monday i like
him because he did this but tuesday i
don't like him because he said this
really bad thing but wednesday we're
back on team trump like you can't it's
you own it all like you can't stay no
for one and yes for another and that
goes for anyone you either own it all or
you say nope i'm done yeah i'm not with
him yeah you know i i when he was
president i would ask people you know
that that would quote unquote support
him you know they it may be really you
know publicly they're really soft like
when you're talking to him because they
can sense they could sense my my uh
a little bit of aggression that i had
towards it and i'd be like so what what
is it that you like about him and it
would
never skip the beat he tells it like it
is that's what they'd say and then and
then i'd say in this in the same almost
the same moment i'd say so what didn't
you like about him and they said oh wait
those tweets those tweets i'm like what
the [ __ ] those are the two exact same
things what the [ __ ] are you talking
about it's like you're saying you like
you like that he tells it like it is but
you don't like when he tells it like it
is like get that out of here the same
[ __ ] people that you're talking about
are the same people you say to him do
you like obamacare [ __ ] no i don't like
that damn obamacare i don't like that
[ __ ] okay do you like the aca hell yeah
you dumb [ __ ] it's the same
thing
right
it's the same group of people like yeah
it's the same
really yeah it's it is insane when you
know you call two different things the
same thing it's the same group of people
who will say
uh donald trump should get credit for
for getting the vaccine out he got it he
got it done quick he got it done real
quick and you're like okay cool so
you're going to get it no no so vaccine
good right yeah
he cut through the red tape he got it
done you know and then you're like so
you're going to take it oh no no it was
rushed it was rushed
and they're talking about you're
absolutely right and to be honest with
you operation warm speed did get this
[ __ ] up pretty fast but how pathetic of
a [ __ ] is trump that his own
team couldn't get him to stay on point
and push it because i'm gonna tell you
something i believe this and i've said
it on my show and i'll stand by it
if trump would have [ __ ] 50 percent
done more for coving he probably would
have beat biden in the election yeah
because they voted because they hate he
made people hate his [ __ ] guts okay
and that's why you added to me you had
historic numbers come out but if he
would have handled covet 50 not even 100
percent better than what he did
the [ __ ] guy got as you know
about 12.2 more million votes the second
time around after charlottesville after
kids in k after after standing look
what that song [ __ ] said
i believe putin in helsinki in 2017 i
know it's funny what i'm about to say
but i mean i mean it they should have
[ __ ] gassed up air force one
left his ass sitting there and said
you're a [ __ ] traitor swim your ass
back to america and when you get back
with 25th amendment your ass because
you're a competitor dan coats i believe
it was the dni or whatever [ __ ] it was
they sat right there in the front row
their [ __ ] jaws hit the ground
that was [ __ ] treason not because
brad berkowitz says it was treason right
i don't give a [ __ ] if you hate bush
reagan bush jr eisenhower every [ __ ]
republican since abraham lincoln you've
never seen
to my knowledge publicly
and especially behind a bully pope but a
president of the republican party say
that [ __ ] russia is okay that i
believe putin over our people
that's [ __ ] insanity
about stuff
the truth is as much as they hate the
republicans you have to be [ __ ] fair
show me a republican president that said
that russia
and putin
uh in particular was good
you got one well i'll i'll show i'll
show you all kinds of people on fox news
i'll show you uh congress people
congress women i'll show you senators
i'll i'll show you governors i'll show
you talking heads commentators i'll show
you i'll show you american nazis that
that that purport to be america first
year i'll show you all kinds of them and
the reason why is because that
[ __ ] stood there in helsinki and
said that [ __ ] the reason why those
people that that's that i think you guys
said it last night on the on the [ __ ]
interview that that son of a [ __ ] there
was racism in our country there was
fascism in our country it was all hiding
underneath rocks yeah he just gave them
[ __ ] permission when he came down
that escalator and said that stupid
racist ass [ __ ] and kept on it and kept
on it and kept on it when he was
president when he said that [ __ ] and did
that [ __ ] and then when he purported the
big lie after the election and didn't
actually make sure that this country had
a vaccine delivered which he could have
done if he would have put as much
[ __ ] effort into delivering the
vaccine to this country as he put into
the big lie he would actually have a
[ __ ] legacy today and he doesn't and
that son of a [ __ ]
but you know what the same people were
talking about the same racist [ __ ]
bastards because i don't know if you
remember this when charlottesville went
down there was a clown that they
interviewed and i remember sitting at a
picnic table and he wound up getting
arrested he was talking all this [ __ ] on
social media and then they arrested him
he was mad because he found out he could
not believe that his lord and savior
donald trump allowed his daughter to
marry a jew who was jared kushner
this like like i told gabe yesterday
whoever it was i think it was gay
charlottesville it might have been uh uh
jim uh piddick from uh best in show
this son of a [ __ ] his daughter
converted to judaism or she's got a
jewish name i forget what it is
because jared's family insisted who when
they got married his grandkids are
[ __ ] jewish so how in the [ __ ]
can you say out your mouth that there
are five people on both sides when those
other people were saying jews were the k
word blood and soil which is nazi [ __ ]
they will not replace us so when this
particular guy found out that
he let ivanka his girlfriend marry
uh jared which i don't know how they
were able to do that because i thought
they were he was married the daughter
was married to the father the way they
act
he flipped his [ __ ] mind because he's
like she he i'm not cool with that
your [ __ ] grandkids are jewish and
you still place it when have you ever
had a president where they said in
pittsburgh with the synagogues don't
come we don't want the president to come
because he's such and i read it on a
show one time the exact kind oh i read
it on when i interviewed jordi uh
masalas i read that or it was jordy i
can't remember but the exact words they
asked him don't come when have you ever
seen him not want a president to come to
kind of unite the country and i don't
give a [ __ ] what they say about
president biden the one thing i do feel
even though he drives me nuts when he
says mitch is my friend he's not your
friend the republicans are not your
friends please president biden a lot of
respect for you but stop the night he'll
be watching he'll definitely be watching
yeah he'll be i'll make sure you watch
him
watch he watches our show every year
well you've been yeah but you're the
midas network we got a fifth oh that
might be that well that's it could be a
flip of the coin you never know it's
possible right
maybe maybe please stop saying it maybe
president biden will be a big fan of
ours have enjoyed you know i i wouldn't
i wouldn't mind if uh if biden tuned in
maybe i could you know like like fox
news used to send signals to trump like
tell him what to say you know i just i
could just tell biden what to say and
then it would all be good right
but one point i was making it was i
honestly believe in my heart that he
wanted to unite the country yeah but you
know when i had anthony on my show and
we did a post uh post election and
anthony said we got to give the 74.2
million offer him i didn't completely
agree but i understood what he was
saying because if we could peel away
some of them maybe we could get the
the flashing light like a men in black
like zap their brains and bring them
back to reality or whatever
but you know what we're 15 months into
president biden and vice president
harris's
uh administration they're not coming off
they double down and triple down right
and those aren't rallies to make america
great again or win america back they're
for him to [ __ ] griff because
you got a [ __ ] so-called billionaire
which i don't believe he is i believe he
has money and he'll never starve are the
three of us starving is starving this
bastard will never starve because
somebody he'll griften and get money
right a billionaire doesn't beg for you
to play for trump force one what the
[ __ ] is that
well an actual an actual billionaire
would just buy a new [ __ ] exactly
right they would just buy or or they
would just charter or they would just
charter whatever exactly that they
wanted they wouldn't buy a plane they
just tried whatever [ __ ] jet they
wanted and typically the stan the way
that it goes like after you're done with
your presidency you're like okay cool
like i focus on my library and do that
for the next book i'll make it right
i'll do a memoir yeah yeah wait a second
wait a second you guys are talking about
things you're saying trump's gonna write
and he's gonna open up
book factory and all kinds of [ __ ] this
is this is it'll be italian the library
will be a big porta potty it'll be fine
but but at the end of the day it's like
yeah typically presidents like kind of
go off and do their own thing for a
while have you have you ever seen an
ex-president republican or democrat
let's just take bush jr
you know bush jr is probably
95 percent against everything that
president obama did right but did he
ever open his mouth
not once and he was painting he was
painting yeah he was painting right i
know he's hated i know he
they duke this with the weapons of mass
destruction there's a lot on this tab i
i agree
but he did what is norms you know like
they talk about taxes and going to
inauguration there's nothing in the
constitution that says the president has
to give us taxes or he has to go to the
inauguration but it's norms that we've
become used to peaceful transition of
power we have never in our lifetimes i
guys i've got you guys
by probably between 10 and 20 years and
age
we've never seen ex-president
act like this and the fact that the
republicans doubled down on his [ __ ]
instead of getting they should have got
rid of him they had the perfect
opportunity to drop this [ __ ]
and if they didn't have if stop this
stealing gabe talked about this
yesterday if stop the steel didn't do it
january 6 if you are a true american and
i'm going to say this i want to record
because i say that much all the time
i served that box 20 [ __ ] years and
28 days during war and peace two wars
one in country and one from the pentagon
and any [ __ ] veteran
that was there on january 6 or any
[ __ ] veteran that says that was an
insurrection and talks about their
political prisoners nelson mandela was a
political prisoner stephen biekel was a
political prisoner like that flag that
sent me off that you talked about the
beginning
j6 will never forget you that
[ __ ] are traitors and any
military person that's okay
still with trump and okay with january
6th because they want to see pelosi get
killed or they want it they thought that
bigoted want to put his [ __ ] feet up
on her desk that piece of [ __ ] is oh is
it american you negate your service and
you defecate on your service and you're
not a [ __ ] patriot you're far you're
anything but a patriot it's bad enough
you support trump still who called us
suckers and losers who treat us like
[ __ ] who didn't go to the [ __ ]
cemetery because he didn't want his
[ __ ] hair to get wet
okay all of it many many things who said
john mccain wasn't a war hero you
[ __ ] that would have ended
anybody else's run but it didn't end
trump and the hollywood access tape
it's not it's the [ __ ] that he said was
bad but the point that people
they steer away from even his [ __ ]
best wife which that's not grammatically
correct drives me nuts i'm talking about
boy
the [ __ ] said because he's
donald trump
he could move on them like a [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] rape not because they
were enamored with him because of who he
was he could do what the [ __ ] he wanted
to do and he's got more cases against
him for sexual harassment and everything
else and it just nothing [ __ ] sticks
and if they don't get him for something
and he runs in 2024 i know a lot of
people come to my show say no way brad
he's not gonna win again i'm telling you
he got a good [ __ ] chance of winning
because
a segment of this society is [ __ ] up
and they always want to blame the
[ __ ] at these rallies with the
[ __ ] hats on all this [ __ ]
they're not his guys you notice as well
as i do that's not all of his backers
you got a lot of rich people behind the
scenes that don't want nothing to do
with him but loved his tax breaks and
love what he did with putting kids in
cages but they won't say it publicly
because they don't want to hurt their
[ __ ] brand right right there's a very
good chance that soma [ __ ] could win in
2024 and because people are so stupid
and they blame president and buy them
for the gas crisis and for this though
no president has anything to do with the
[ __ ] gas plus
but they believe it and they double down
on it and they get news cycles on it
well i what a knockout punch uh from
brad burke which speaking and i don't
mean to switch gears like this but
speaking of knockout punch there's a
knockout punch here that i want you to
tell a story about
um i i have this hanging up here behind
me it's from 1965
it is when muhammad ali
uh knocked out well some say he did some
say he didn't um but i'll let you tell
the story a lot of people bring up this
painting
yeah so this so this is one photo shot
of it um i really like this particular
photo shot um when the champ is standing
over him there's a couple other angles
and a couple other shots but this is the
one that i i like the most that's why i
have it hanging up behind me but you
have a special story about this this
picture that i have hanging right behind
me yourself yeah i interviewed angelo
dundee he was very kind to me over the
years i mentioned him in my hall of fame
speech when i got inducted last year he
trained muhammad ali and
he told me that it was a punch he said
brad i know what they said it was fixed
it was this it was that it was a punch
now i know they show different angles
and all of that stuff but i honest
honestly believe angelo and noah and ali
i don't i don't i don't feel this just
might be that ollie would have taken uh
would allow that to happen him to knock
him out because if you know the whole
story when he was the youngest
heavyweight champion when he beat him in
64 at the convention center on miami
beach and and sonny couldn't come out at
a corner they actually put something on
sonny's gloves this is the first fight
and it got in ollie's i holly wanted
cassius clay then he wanted it he wanted
to quit
and he went on he wound up stopping
sunday listen sonny liston was a monster
he was mike tyson back then without the
you know without him saying robin i love
you robin you know he didn't have that
i shouldn't say that because i know mike
you're gonna kill me for this but
i don't believe it was a phantom punch i
i from everything that i know it was a
legitimate knockout now uh angelo was
the trainer at the fight too yeah
he was he was there at the so so he
wasn't just at the fight he was the
actual trainer his trainer he trained
him i i think there was only one
fight and i could be wrong about this
that ali
i mean i'm sorry angelo didn't work
because he had two fighters jimmy ellis
who was from kentucky who was a
heavyweight champion and ollie and they
fought each other and i don't i don't
think i can't remember if angela worked
ellis's corner or he didn't work i think
he did him he might have worked at ellis
corner again and muhammad stopped i'm
pretty sure he stopped jimmy ellis
but um
but yeah he was there and that's what he
told me it wasn't a phantom punch so
what when when did you have this uh when
did you talk to angelo about the well i
talked to him many times over the years
but i interviewed him i didn't talk
about the phantom punch in my book i
don't think i did but my book is called
boxing interviews of a lifetime i
interviewed him in 2000 uh for my book
but i had talked to him subsequently
since then and i was at the hall of fame
with him in 2001. not not my hall of
fame but the international boxing hall
of fame which is uh in canada new york
so before we go tell us a little bit
about because a lot of people may not
know this about bad brad berkwit but he
is in the florida hall of fame boxing
hall of fame so tell us a little bit
about being what it means to be in the
florida boxing hall of fame but also i
want you to give us shameless plug of
your website where to find you uh where
to get your book if people want to read
it and where to watch your show okay let
me do that and i'll tell you florida
yeah go ahead so on youtube just type in
ringside report web web tv channel come
right up
ringsidereport.com i got a great writing
team there lots of diversity
all kinds of articles lgbtq social
issues um you you name it we've got it's
not just sports i've got pretty much
sports is the least of it right now
because what's going on in america i
want writers together doing all that um
on twitter it's at bad brad rsr and i
always i always interact and uh
so hit me up there as well and like i
said
ringsidereport.com and my personal my
if you want to keep up with guests it's
bad brad
berkwith
tuttis.com is my my personal website so
florida
florida boxing hall of fame tony again
my father it all goes back to my father
my father knew some of the legends of
the sport he met cassius clay in the 60s
tried to hustle him on a car that he was
selling
wait wait you're dead your dad tried to
hustle uh cash display at the time that
would i i would actually that would be
great foot too bad that footage
you know what i mean so i don't know if
it was a student i told this this story
in my induction speech he was he was
friends with fighters like kid gavilan
and bo jackie drove cross country with a
very famous fighter named rocky graciano
was championing the world from new york
only problem is they met at miami beach
i didn't have a driver's license but my
dad still drove in rocky grazie
new york and i always said that and when
he got his license it wasn't much better
because
my dad would drive on a [ __ ] sidewalk
but
i got inducted yeah for
being a journalist for the boxing side
but my amateur boxing journalist my book
oh boxing interviews of a lifetime is
the book it's on all of the platforms
although house you know um
authorhouse.com amazon all of them
so
loving a sport from when i was seven
boxing as an amateur 883
and then 1997 making my bones doing
interviews that was the uh that was my
my induction into the office honor of a
lifetime you know i wish sadly i wish my
dad was there he was there in spirit
it's the only part of my speech i really
did get choked up about
debbie was there and you know debbie is
the nucleus behind my show she she's
behind it well she used to be behind the
camera until zoom but she's the one that
you know bounce ideas off what do you
think it is what do you think of that
she'll send me stuff she's she's kind of
like my my silent producer on all of
this but yeah but in honor of a lifetime
absolute honor of a lifetime well we're
we're glad that even though even though
um you've kind of stepped slightly away
from the boxing world you're still in
the ring side in america right for not
only not only
politics but democracy itself because
here we we want to promote anything
that's pro-democracy and uh brad you're
always you're a good friend to me and um
uh we we've
talked several times and i i appreciate
having your friendship and and not only
that always come back to the show don't
don't think that uh you're not welcome
back you're definitely welcome back here
uh because uh forget about it right
forget about it
for your viewers if you really want to
see and gabe you've probably noticed for
or you might know it i don't know but if
you ever want to see a great breakdown
of forget about it watch donnie brasco
and watch the scene when paul giamatti
who was a small much smaller actor than
now he's huge he's on millions in all
these shows
he asked donnie
john
johnny depp's character donnie brasco
which based on joe pistone was the real
guy he says what he would forget about
and he explains about it's a gets a good
explanation because forget about could
mean many different things right right
right right and i want to say to you
guys i didn't get a chance to tell you
tony i know i told you privately but
again congratulations to both of you
guys getting on the midas touchdown
thank you thank you very much
i love that they're they're pushing your
platform out because you guys in your
own your own way and i love what you're
doing is moving humanity forward and we
need there's more of us like i told i
said it gave yesterday there's more of
us
not everybody's comfortable using their
platform or speaking out i'm okay with
that not everybody's made for the life
that we have completely chosen at this
point and a lot of times at a personal
cost but i appreciate what you're doing
and you know you got my support but we
are free and like i said i say i say
forget about it you guys say [ __ ] them
that's it [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
well thanks for joining us brad everyone
stick around brad you're always welcome
back thank you very much uh for for
being here everyone stick around we'll
be right back after this break